this morning on the dish chef Jeremiah
Langhorne born and raised in Virginia as
a teen he delivered pizzas for a local
restaurant then he went behind the
counter and started making them and that
started a culinary career that's taken
him to top venues from Copenhagen to
California now he's returned to his
mid-atlantic roots with the dabney in
Washington DC the foods largely local
sourced from the region's finest farms
and prepared in a wood-burning hearth in
2016
food and wine named it one of their
restaurants of the year chef Jeremiah
Lang jardin good morning welcome to the
dish thank you for having this is quite
a table tell us about so we've got a lot
of different things going on here we've
got some braised beef short ribs
um over on the right we have some
oysters white stone oysters from
Virginia the little country ham
vinaigrette
some radishes Mar garden with buttermilk
dressing beautiful some chard squash
over some kale with some ricotta and
some feta and then this one is chard
brassicas which is a fun family of
vegetables with a little bit of fried
shallot and then in the front corner
there we've got some toast charred
Brussels sprouts chestnuts some few more
radishes and then for dessert
butterscotch pie
but of course and what is in this glass
that I can smell from over here so that
is called the Navy Yard it's one of the
cocktails we serve in Washington yep so
in DC there's a neighborhood called the
Navy Yard it's a great cocktail lime
juice Jamaican rum really fun refreshing
but still kind of feels like winter it
is nice I think I like the cocktail more
than even the neighborhood pizza
delivery guy to a man that's dodged at
some of the best restaurants in the
world what was the moment you realized
you wanted to not be delivering pizzas
but to be making food you know it was
really interesting previously I guess I
mean I was a kid I was 16 so I didn't
really realize how food worked and
gotten back to the restaurant from
delivering pizzas and I saw guys in the
kitchen and they were just throwing
things together like there was clearly
no
recipe there was clearly no rhyme or
reason they're just throwing things
together
and it kind of struck me is I previously
thought everyone just followed a recipe
right right and I realized wow you have
the ability to just create whatever you
want and no one's gonna tell you that
it's wrong or right necessarily you can
just have that level of creativity and I
think I was hooked you ended up getting
a job in a restaurant in Charlottesville
which is if you've said is kind of was
kind of your cooking school yeah there's
a there was a wonderful little
restaurant in Charlottesville called
oXXO and a guy named John Haywood who
was the chef/owner and he kind of agreed
to take me on as you know essentially an
apprentice and I worked up through the
ranks there and that acted is
essentially my culinary school but
tenacity is your calling card right I
mean you use that to get a gig with Sean
Brock the great celebrated southern chef
tell us how that happened I didn't
realize this I now fully understand how
annoying it must have been seven 2008
when the economy wasn't so good I was
going down and knocking on their door
saying hire me hire me hire me hire me
and I just didn't give up and at the
time they weren't you know not only were
they not hiring but they were having to
lay people off and it was a tough time
but I just kept showing back up you got
a tip about how what to do exactly Tim I
befriended the chef's there and one of
them called me and said hey we're we're
down to ours pretty much our skeleton
crew and there's a guy who's going to be
leaving yeah so I bet if you were to
come down here and be here the same day
that he puts in his notice
hot tip yeah Sean would probably hire
you and luckily it worked out Wow just
looked at you and said you want the job
with your goal always to open your own
kitchen yeah I think I always from
pretty early on I think's a doc so I
started thinking about opening my own
restaurant eventually you do something
weird or innovative you you have people
in the restaurants trade places from
time to time yeah you know there's a lot
of learning curves and restaurants and
when you go from being a chef your whole
career to then being a chef owner you
adopt a whole new set of
responsibilities and as an owner your
number one responsibility is to make
sure that everybody does the best job
they can so that all the guests have a
great experience and very quickly
realize that if people really understood
how difficult other people's jobs were
it would just make everything so much
smoother and so much easier
and it does yeah Eddie Murphy had it
right trading places yeah there's a
hundred percent chef is asked you to
sign this dish if you could share this
incredible meal with anyone past or
present who would it be you know what I
I think I would share with my wife a
winner all the time
Jeremiah Langhorne thank you and thanks
for sharing and for more on chefs
Langhorne and the dish head to our
website at CBS this morning calm